covid19 is making another health crisis
even worse in our country drug overdoses
the cdc saying we're seeing a record
number of deaths recently and the
pandemic is playing a part in it
arko mana joining us now live to explain
why and also what kind of help is
available
both niece and brian the national drug
helpline recently placed nevada
at an increased risk for overdose deaths
experts say that's because the pandemic
is putting
a strain on our mental health and that
is really causing some issues and for
some people
they turn to drugs to cope it's truly
a one day at a time situation the road
to recovery is not easy
take it from courtney olsen who became
addicted to meth in high school
although she's now 10 years into her
recovery coven 19 isolation has
presented the possibility of a relapse
when you're up here in your head it's a
dangerous neighborhood to be driving
around by yourself the cdc says drug
overdose deaths most notably involving
opioids are accelerating during covet
19. there were over 81 thousand between
may 2019 and may 2020
the highest number ever recorded the
largest increases coinciding with state
shutdowns during the pandemic and it's
not slowing down
just last month nevada was placed on red
alert status
they're using heavily more than they
have
jennifer roman works at desert hope
addiction treatment center where she's
seeing an alarming trend among patients
in recent months
many times we've had to revive them
because of the amount of
[Music]
drugs that are in their system to combat
this crisis experts say early
intervention and more access to naloxone
and opioid overdose antidote are
critical
for courtney it's also about staying
connected whether it's attending virtual
recovery meetings or supporting others
during this tough time
by me helping somebody else that helps
keep
me sober
now if you or someone you know is
struggling with drug use especially now
during the pandemic
you can call crisis support services of
nevada that number
is 1-800-273-8255 and we have links to
more resources
on our website 8newsnow.com reporting
live in las vegas tonight orco mana 8
news now